[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a short film called 2081
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins with a narration in the
background that the year is 2081 and
finally everyone is equal in every
sector people aren't equal just by law
or god they are now equal in each and
every way nobody is smarter better
looking quicker or stronger than anybody
else the narration continues saying that
all equality is possible because of the
211th 212th and 213th amendments done to
the constitution
of the state it was only possible
because of the unceasing vigilance of
the united states handicapper general
the strong people are compelled to wear
more weight to make them feel weaker the
intelligent wear earpieces that
frequently fire radio noises to keep
them away from taking unfair advantage
of their brain and the beautiful people
wear masks in places where their beauty
can be found distracting it is called
the golden age of equality despite all
the equality some things about living
are still not right we are then taken
back to a scene where some police
officers barge inside a house to take a
guy away in front of his elderly parents
back in the present the guy's father
george bergeron is trying to fix the tv
signal since he is wearing the earpieces
too he can barely remember about his son
being taken away by the government as he
is distracted by small flashbacks of his
son being dragged out his wife hazel
reminds him that he has to fix the tv he
then inserts a tube-like device behind
the television to start it the
television is showing a graceful ballet
dance being performed by a group of
beautiful ladies the ladies are dancing
while wearing some weights around their
neck and arms they are also wearing
masks so that they don't look superior
to anyone meanwhile george is again
having some flashbacks about the past
but as he tries to remember more about
the incident the interference from the
earpiece cuts him off his wife is also
able to hear the distracting noise and
asks him how it was to which george
replies that it was loud she mentions
that she heard the sound of someone
hitting a milk bottle with a hammer she
also adds that it must be good to hear
different sounds every day george
replies that it isn't pleasing as it
disturbs him hazel further adds that if
she was the handicapper general she
would add the noise of the chimes which
would be pleasing to hear and would also
honor the religion she also thinks that
she would make a good handicapper
general and george agrees with her
instinct on the television we can still
see the beautiful girls performing the
ballet dance after some time george
again has the visions of the policemen
taking away his son harrison forcefully
but just like the previous times he is
distracted by the noise in the earpiece
seeing this hazel feels that he is just
tired and suggests he could take some
rest by placing the handicaps on the
pillows she thinks that he always seems
to be worn out and wants to make him
feel light-headed in any way possible
however george immediately denies her
request and tells her that if he takes
the handicaps off for once he will feel
like keeping them off every time he also
reminds her how she would feel if he is
without the handicaps hazel replies that
she would hate it and answers that they
can't do anything about that here we get
to know that removing any form of
disability is a crime by law hence
everyone has to abide by the rules even
at home meanwhile the ballet dance
program on the television is interrupted
to present breaking news hazel gets mad
due to the interruption for presenting
the same old news as the news reporter
tries to present the breaking news he
stammers continuously because of which
the broadcast is stopped for a while
despite the wasted effort hazel feels
that the news reporter tried his best to
present the news and his salary must be
increased by looking at his efforts this
implies that all the citizens have been
brainwashed into acting equal even
inside the home they show traits of
equality after this hazel gets up from
the couch and heads into the kitchen to
get the dishes done while she is doing
the dishes the news resumes with a news
reporter he says that they have received
a warning from the handicapper general
that a suspected anarchist harrison
bergeron has escaped from police custody
he presents that harrison was arrested
six years ago for propagandist vandalism
broadcast piracy refusal to report his
quarterly handicapping evaluations and a
blatant removal of his handicaps in a
public place despite the fact that
bergeron was in tight security he
vanished miraculously the reporter
advises the public to be aware of him as
he is a genius and an athlete who is
under handicapped and extremely
dangerous while george is listening to
the news carefully hazel can't hear it
due to the water flowing from the tap
the reporter then concludes his report
requesting the public to contact the
local authorities if they see harrison
nearby after the news is over the ballet
dancing program continues suddenly the
ballet girls start to hear a thumping
sound this is heard by everyone through
the television as well george quickly
recognizes the sound to be of his son
harrison and utters his name harrison
appears with all of his body chained
dragging one of the security guards to
the stage after reaching the stage he
starts urging everyone present there to
be silent and to listen to him he leaves
the security guard he was grabbing and
tells everyone that there is a bomb
underneath the building whose detonator
is in his hands the other security
guards are seen approaching him from
behind but as soon as he takes out the
detonator they run away from the stage
harrison then strongly suggests everyone
remain in their seats in the kitchen
hazel is still washing the dishes and is
completely unaware about the incidents
happening on the television at the
theater harrison stomps his leg loudly
on the ground and apologizes with
everyone present there for interrupting
their entertainment he adds that
hopefully he could provide some sort of
entertainment himself he then introduces
himself and mentions that he is a
fugitive a public threat and an
abomination of the abel he also calls
himself the greatest man everyone has
never known harrison further reveals
that he has been held prisoner by the
state for the last six years without any
trial and with torture which has no end
he explains that the state tried to
destroy every trace of extraordinary
lying inside of him but they were unable
to do so he says that he is standing in
front of them being beaten hobbled and
sickened but not broken harrison then
says that they must destroy the enemy
who is hiding in the darkness he
suggests everyone shine their lights so
that all the world can notice them after
finishing his speech he rips apart his
handicaps and throws them on the floor
the audience in the theater are
astounded by this as they have been
blinded by the government at home george
is shocked to see his son doing all of
this on television meanwhile hazel is
still busy doing the dishes in the next
scene as a guy escapes the theater he
comes across a battalion of armed police
forces along with the handicapper
general the head officer asks the bomb
disposal team about the status of the
bomb to which they reply that they will
need some time to work it out we also
see that various groups of the police
forces are placed at different locations
inside the theater harrison asks for a
volunteer to display his next trick when
no one from the audience accepts to be
his volunteer he turns his head towards
the group of ballet dancers one of the
dancers reluctantly accepts and starts
removing her handicaps when she
approaches harrison he removes her mask
and whispers something into her ear he
then asks the musicians to play some
music outside the police force is ready
to enter the theater just then group e
of the force the bomb specialists inform
the head officer that the bomb has been
successfully disarmed the head officer
then contacts the television broadcaster
to stop the live broadcast back inside
the theater harrison is listening to the
music played by live musicians but he
suddenly asks them to stop he then
orders one of the cellists to play the
violin for him the cellist obliges in
fear and starts playing the violin
gracefully the music suits everyone
present in the office at home george is
also enjoying the music being played
however his joy turns to grief as the
broadcast is stopped unexpectedly the
head officer also receives a message
from the broadcasting unit that the live
broadcast has been stopped he then
orders all of his units to stand by for
entry into the theater inside harrison
starts dancing with the ballerina while
holding the detonator in his hands as he
senses that the troops are about to
enter he presses the detonator which
activates one of the systems underground
while this doesn't blow anything up it
resumes the interrupted tv broadcast
once again seeing his son back on tv
again george's face lights up meanwhile
harrison and the ballerina continue
dancing while the police force and the
handicapper general enter the theater
she takes the head officer's gun and
marches towards harrison just then the
head officer finds out through his
earpiece that the event is being
broadcast live he quickly rushes to stop
the handicapper general but it's too
late harrison is shot by the lady and he
lies flat on the stage the head officer
reaches the stage and the general
finally realizes that she is live on air
the television broadcast also ends and
hazel finally finishes doing her dishes
george is distraught by what he saw but
when he tries to think more of it he is
interrupted by the loud frequency from
his earpiece when hazel asks what's
wrong he simply replies that he doesn't
remember but he saw something sad on the
television hazel then suggests that he
forgets sad things like she always does
the movie ends as a confused george gets
up to get some drinks from the
refrigerator while hazel hums the music
from the ballet dance
this film represents the future where
equality has become dominant but at the
same time freedom has become
non-existent anyone promoting freedom is
apprehended and punished just like
harrison was what's scary is that the
way our society is progressing this
sci-fi short movie may turn out to be
the real in the not-so-distant future
people have been unfairly demanding
equality despite lacking the ability to
match other deserving candidates the
time may come when even the intelligent
and gifted people may not be able to
showcase their talents in a world where
everything is equal there may be no
freedom
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching